le jeune accusé pour réaliser des
grandes choses il faut d'abord rêvé
c'est clair elle parlait de ses rêves
éveillés solide auquel on s'accroche
quand tout va mal de ceux qui ont fait
de ce temps font des sites et des douala
un samuel eto'o de ceux qui ont fait
d'un enfant métisse abandonné quelque
part hawaii barack obama ou de ceux qui
ont fait ce jeune avocat dans les années
le futur président d'afrique du sud j'ai
rêvé grands petite confidence quand
j'étais jeune enfin beaucoup plus jeune
j'ai toujours rêvé de changer l'amérique
je sais c'est très prétentieux mais la
vie va comme elle va elle m'a rattrapé
et j'ai rangé mes rêves d'enfant dans
une armoire
je me suis attelé à construire une vie
plus solide plus stable entre la mère de
famille et la chef d'entreprise
j'avais beaucoup de temps au leur
réalisme et très peu pour mes rêves puis
un matin comme on dit une mouche m'a
piqué une mouche l'a piqué et j'ai eu
envie de me lever de me battre une
obsession un truc de dingue
pas de plan précis pas de stratégie tout
a été instinctif un des premiers
réflexes ne pas rester seul et de
m'entourer du plus grand nombre d'
intelligence aussi
le vrai déclic se fait en fait il ya
quatre ans un repas trois amis et on
veut c'est là on s'est rendu compte
qu'on ne savait pas ce que faisait
l'autre qu on était amis qu'on se
fréquenter mais qu'on avait jamais pris
le temps d'analyser le business de
l'autre et de voir les possibilités de
travailler ensemble
c'est à ce moment précis que j'ai
compris que s'il y avait un combat à
mener ce combat commencer
obligatoirement à cet endroit là qu'il
fallait apprendre à nous connaître à
nous faire confiance entre congolais
entre américains et osé rêver des
synergies fortes changer le congo puis
l'afrique
le lendemain j'ai décroché mon téléphone
j'ai appelé j'ai appris j'ai appelé le
pays compte tellement d'échec
dès qu'il s'agit d'associations entre
congolais de regroupement d'africains
que j'avais l'impression d'avoir le
premier rôle dans titanic
après les coups de fil les courriers par
centaines et je vous ai pas toutes les
critiques en permanence toutes ces
attaques gratuites face auquel il m'a
fallu très difficilement très
difficilement rester sourde et muette
heureusement l'année mais trois grandes
copines qui ne m'ont pas lâché et elles
sont dans la salle merci à toi rage
merci à toi résilience je n'ai pas vu
ténacité
merci à toi ténacité vous pouvez les
applaudir ce qui était un repas il ya
quatre ans s'est transformée en un
réseau de 500 décideurs un réseau de 500
décideurs d'ici et d'ailleurs qui ont su
dialoguer recevoir les présidents
les ministres des intellectuels les élus
les artistes et toutes ces têtes bien
faites que compte l'afrique
la force de ce réseau restera pour
toujours ce qu'il a été initié par des
africains entre africains et que c'est
lui qui invite le monde à dialoguer et
pas l'inversé
ce réseau et respire à l'américaine avec
ses codes ses faiblesses ses forces mais
peu importe le fait est qu'il est né et
il va grandir et un jour un jour on
prend nous invitera pour en parler
africa est l'un des hits chicago
represented by dad 10h06
une chose que je sais une chose que je
sais ce que ce réseau sera montré que
l'afrique détient une clé indispensable
au monde
nous sommes la clé je pourrais résumer
ça en une simple phrase l'afrique manque
au monde l'afrique manque au monde
répéter avec moi la fri morts mais
quelle afrique
quelle est cette amérique qui manque au
monde
elle est cette afrique qui détient une
quête indispensable
on va faire court je vais commencer par
vous dire ce à quoi elle ne ressemble
pas cette afrique ne ressemble pas ce
qu'on voit dans les médias
internationaux
bon d'accord comme face régulièrement
des sujets ou des reportages sur la
famine la sécheresse les guerres dont
elle ajouté et africains j'ai pas de
souci avec ça d'abord c'est de l'info
sincère c'est de l'info ça mobilise du
monde et ça fait appel à une université
à une solidarité universelle bon qu'on
me montre pour la deuxième fois à la
tête des lions des zèbres des éléphants
dans le serengeti
j'ai pas de problème les enfants adorent
mais ce que eux ils savent que nos
enfants ils ont le portable
ils ont facebook ils ont vu le dernier
fils de rihanna avec d'une sait qui ils
sont fans des kardashian
ils attendent le prochain galaxie x blue
enfin bref que nos enfants sont pareils
que leurs homologues européens ou
américains
mais je vous vois venir vous vous dites
ah oui elle parle de ses enfants avec le
portable les écrans ils sont connectés
elle part de cette afrique bourgeoise
non non mon afrique ne ressemble pas non
plus à cette bourgeoisie africaine où on
peut le dire ici qui se la pète un peu
et qui a une petite tendance à
photocopier l'attitude du côlon même
dans la relation avec son frère mon
afrique notre pas dans les logiques
victimaire qui voudraient le grand
complot de l'occident contre l'afrique
dans lequel on aime parfois s'installer
si pas se vautrer afin d'oublier de
parler de nos propres faiblesses
c'est un prix qui fait de l'autre un
ennemi permanent ne m'intéresse pas je
préfère je préfère laisser ça à ceux qui
veulent brûler mandela je vous entends
vous dites ah oui mais connaît pas
l'intrigué
n'allez pas penser n'allez pas penser
que je sois dans le déni face aux rôles
sombres des antichambres de pouvoir en
occident ou ailleurs n'allez pas penser
que je ne sache pas ce que sont la
françafrique où les contrats léonins et
le mal qui continue à faire à l'afrique
n'allez pas imaginer que je me voile la
face devant les trafics en tous genres
des multinationales pour échapper à
l'impôt pour utiliser nos forces vives
sont jamais les respecter ou détruire
nos terres alors n'allez surtout pas
imaginer que je ne sache pas de quoi on
parle
quand on me parle des pillages des
ressources naturelles je sais tout ça je
sais ce qui se passe en afrique
mais quand je vous dis que cette afrique
là n'est pas la mienne je vous parle
uniquement de cette afrique qui manque
de solidarité de solidarité nationale
continentale face à ces mêmes pleo car
finalement quelle solidarité
quelle solidarité entre congolais quelle
solidarité africaine avons-nous su
mettre en place face à ces fléaux
au délà de ces coquilles vides étaient
ces concepts ostentatoire décliné à
longueur de conférence où la question
africaine
que faisons-nous ensemble face
fléau face à ces agressions répétées
comme le ferait n'importe quel peuple
agressé mon afrique l'afrique dont je
vous parle afrique dont je rêve
elle a su retrouver le sens des mots
solidarité fraternité entre les ethnies
au sein même des nations qui la
composent entre les états cette afrique
elle est pacifique
elle assure rassembler échanger se
concerter à son rythme tout en
respectant la sagesse des anciens et en
affichant son insolente modernité on
africa mois et ne copie pas elle ne
placez pas grossièrement les européens
ou les américains m'ont africa mois s
invente elle se réinvente en permanence
elle le fait pour elle et pour le monde
elle a façonné un projet continental
sans mendier et monde y est encore
auprès des grandes puissances
de quoi le financer cette afrique elle
s'est dotée d'une vision d'une vraie
pour son avenir et pour ses enfants
c'est cela mon afrique cette afrique
dont je vous parle
elle est composée de toutes ses
diversités vibrante connectés empathique
cette afrique là à un message qui est
très précis ce message qu'elle détient
une clé et je suis convaincu que si nous
savons par les eaux montent le monde
entendra que l'afrique détient une clé
et qu'avec les autres clés dont dispose
le monde
cette clé là est fondamentale à l'heure
des grands bouleversements sans
précédent qui nous attend tenez le
combat contre le réchauffement
climatique ne se fera pas sans l'afrique
au nom
car le monde aura besoin cette fois ci
d'une réelle solidarité africaine pour
faire face à ce qui se profile et quant
à l'intelligence artificielle dont
chacun sait qu'elle marquera ce siècle
peut-on sincèrement peut-on certains
l'ont amputé des millénaires et de
savoirs africain
si on la veut véritablement intelligente
peut-on ont chassé le peu d'humanité qui
leur reste et nous africains
on nous déchirons on joue avec le monde
le pot de terre contre le pot de fer
nous ne faisons que nous éloigner de ce
que nous sommes ce n'est pas ça la
brique mais par contre troubler le monde
entier à notre manière avec notre
sagesse et notre empathie qui ont
toujours été avec nous troubler le monde
pour remplir les facettes les plus
saillantes les plus blessante peut et
doit devenir le credo de l'afrique
je sais tu sais si nous voulons si nous
voulons que le monde entier commence à
regarder nos valeurs si nous voulons que
le monde commence à regarder nos valeurs
si nous voulons transmettre ce message
au monde
il nous faut à nous tous 100 m unir nos
forces et nos coeurs car si nous
africains ne sont pas en mesure de
porter ces valeurs qui d'autre le fera
si j'y ai cru
si j'ai pu entourer des meilleurs alors
que rien n'était gagné c'est parce que
j'ai osé et l'afrique m'a répondu ça
veut dire que c'est possible ça veut
dire que c'est possible de se rassembler
ça veut dire que c'est possible dans
cette afrique ou réaliser les grandes
choses sont
impossible j'ai aussi appris que tirer
fierté de mon africanité et se
l'approprié donne la force de se battre
pour réaliser ses rêves
le monde nous attend
le monde attend que nous remettions
cette clé pour retrouver son équilibre
pour se réinventer
nous sommes la clé nous sommes la
sagesse nous sommes la fraternité nous
sommes la solidarité nous devons en être
conscients
nous devons arrêter de nous devons
arrêter de regarder dans le rétroviseur
la route sera certainement encore long
mais peu importe je continuerai de me
battre pour que cette afrique qui bat
encore dans nos coeurs pour qu'elle soit
reconnue par le monde pour ce qu'elle
peut lui apporter de grand et de beau
c'est mon rêve c'est vrai est plutôt
grand il est plutôt big mais je le sais
je le sens l'afrique manque au monde
[Applaudissements]